boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host silence sake
I'm very excited to continue being doing
interviews at Co Fez the Congress on the
future of engineering software our first
second annual partnership with them we
are now sitting down with Tom dobro
hello right there my name is Tom
Billroth I'm founder of 21 geo thanks
for coming out of the show and talking
to us really appreciate it thank you
very excited to be learning more about
21 geo and what you're building you're
actually doing one of the presentations
right now that's correct
yeah and so you're explaining you were
explaining to me earlier about your
interest in engineering and building out
what is a bearing that is okay 21 Geo's
technology enables bearings to do more
than go around in a circle they now
support complex motion so the way this
works is it's a computer system some
high-end math computer C++ you give to
arrays okay of two sets of arrays XY and
rotation one set for each component so
the components are going to move
relative to each other and you define
that and then what my software does is
it provides a bearing that will support
that motion there's a great deal of
flexibility this is a brand new
mechanical paradigm on par with gears
cams and linkages it has more
flexibility than anything else in
mechanical engineering today interesting
it has more flexibility than anything
else in mechanical engineering today so
then you're 21 Gio's software would
enable someone that puts in there like
you said they're these the variables
that they would need a bearing to do
more than just have something you spin
around it and you and you then go and
make the model out what how to make the
bearing fit their needs
yes and then so what would what would
what would a bearing like this one be
used for okay that particular one is
half of a speed reducer a speed reducer
okay so if you go on my website you can
see a number of you'll see some speed
reducers on the front page and the link
is 21
21 geometry calm 21 geometry calm links
in the bio everyone Oh huh okay and it
would have I haven't built one yet this
is we've only been public since November
with public with the information yeah
I'm seeking to get it produced I'm not
seeking for a partner to actually finish
the production get it into and license
it yeah but it would have best-in-class
features for robotics and motion control
applications yeah and we need speed
reducers in those cases because servo
motors want to go really fast and
robotic arms don't go anywhere near that
fast okay servo motors go fast like
2,000 rpm and they need to be slowed
down at times because this is probably
20 rpm or yeah 60 rpm sure 20 or 60 rpm
yeah and when it's going like that it
needs to be slowed down right and this
how does this help it slow down well you
put two of them with a different
combination on there and it gives a
difference it's a little complicated you
need to kind of go to the website take a
look at you take a look at it and how it
slows it down interesting because
because the the know what's the normal
process for slowing it down use a
gearbox a gearbox yes the normal process
yeah okay yeah yeah okay and that uses a
lot of energy it also has lash meaning
that there's some sloppiness in it and
so the things move back and forth and it
makes the controllers bad now there's
some specialty gearboxes with very low
lash and on mine I can actually be
because my system has no design friction
in it I get you know these pins roll
freely throughout the motion area yeah
yeah so there's three carry forwards
from a regular bearing that I give it
that are necessary first of all is that
there's always contact between the this
pin here and the two surfaces yeah the
second carry forward is that it rolls
freely so this pin is rolling just like
it would in a ball bearing yeah and then
third is and this is a little less
obvious is that these contact points are
always opposing each other
they're 180 degrees apart always
throughout the range of motion and that
keeps it from jamming Oh interesting
okay their contact points are a hundred
eighty degrees apart apart AHA they're
on opposite ends of the pit the pin yeah
yeah okay okay interesting it's also
cool how this is more like a triangle
shape in this a spherical shape and then
that's how these two things interplay
yeah yeah that's very interesting and
it's a question of the combination is
plus one so you have three three sides
four pins that's plus one and then this
one is five so that's what's going to
drive oh it is plus one I see now yeah
okay well that's interesting yeah but
this is one of a thousand ways you can
use this technology yeah correct okay so
I'm in discussion with a automotive
company that they're redesigning their
cockpits for lay flat for laid for flash
scuse me dude sitter they're redesigning
the cockpits for autonomous driving yeah
and they want to lay flat seat a flat
seats yeah okay and anyone who's been in
business class will tell you it's pretty
common that when the seat goes down
they're not flat yeah yeah okay and this
is even the expensive seats you have in
business class this is hard to do this
is easy for me so what I would do is
just program it with index it with the
rotations so as it rotates down at some
point it starts to move out and then
another point it starts to move down I
get a lady lad out of yeah yeah
interesting it's problem I'm working on
right now that's a great problem to
solve
yeah you're attacked interesting that's
the that's the big thing is that the
seats normally like this and that when
it lays flat that there's not you can't
you haven't moved the seat back as well
as flattened it out right yeah and so
then type of types of technology like
yours can enable processes like lay flat
seats and how would interesting how
would how would your tech enable it to
move back as well as lay flat
well you program into it how you
want the components to move and so once
you get that program then you have to
just you know then I have to sort of
move the pin starting position around so
that I can find a set of motions that
will work for it okay you have to make
sure that there's there's interference
problems you have to work with and
there's you also want to make sure that
it's fully supported yeah okay and the
other industry applications yes yeah so
I have a grant application out for the
National Science Foundation law and the
nature of the grant is to have on my
website you can see what's called
precise motion technology and from that
you will see crankcase replacements and
the crankcase the idea is is if you have
a piston system you want to precisely
determine how that piston is going to go
through the cycle and with the crank
case you don't get to decide that the
crank case does it for you and that's
not maximum efficiency so for instance
we know that one hundred and thirty two
years ago there was a patent for the
Atkinson cycle engine vastly more
efficient engine the toyota corporation
did an experimental engine in 2014 and
got the 38 percent thermal efficiency
which is fantastic considering most cars
operate around 20% or more agency and it
really comes down to just letting the
cylinder go down a little further than
it does on a compression and harvesting
that energy mhm yeah yeah okay so what
you'll see on the website is because of
this very new technology I can get you
know develop an engine crankcase
replacement so that'll be vastly more
efficient it'll be cheaper and I get the
cost down because I can do the the power
strip I do the whole thing at 360
degrees where it takes 720 degrees one
revolution and I reserve 180 degrees for
the power stroke and since it's 180
degrees I only need two cylinders
whereas the minimum or internal
combustion engine right now is four so
the cost is going down you
then finally I can program into it the
mechanical advantage so that I can have
a constant torque output and that's that
will be a pretty revolutionary if I can
pull this off yeah and there's some
shortcomings to it and I you know
there's no doubt about it and that's
with the grant application from the
National Science Foundation is about
it'll take that to the next level this
is this is so interesting that that
you're that you're ma that how did how
did I you know how did these ideas come
to mind this is so cool
you know I wound up out of work and I
was trying to figure out you know what
can I do on my own and so I looked at
this I said this fascinated me I saw
animations like this in college if two
engineering degrees from MIT and so I
said okay let me look at this and so I
went online and said you know how come
these things don't exist in the wild why
aren't there being used and what I came
up with this there was a number of
reasons that they just did wouldn't work
and number one is is that they would Jam
number two is is that that the friction
was no friction was just an assumption
just because you have a rolling system
between two surfaces doesn't mean that
it's going to roll price precisely yeah
there's a patent that goes back to 1920
that looks a lot like that interesting
okay but the rollin on that is an
assertion and if you look at their own
diagrams you'll see that the pin is
being held like this and if pins being
held like that between two surfaces and
emotion out of the way it's going to jam
yeah and then did this this new kind of
what looks like a little like tank
treads almost yeah call them guides
because it's size that's cool
it's a good way to put it they're guides
because you're fitting the guide from
the from the center of the bearing to
these pins yeah and if it gets out of
place the thing doesn't work so the
final intent of the guide is to keep it
very near where it needs to be
correct correct and they won't it won't
move that's one of the keys is that it
won't move unless the guidance is
perfectly in place and and the four pins
hold it in place quite well this is this
is very very very smooth and so then
what would be what would be an
application of one like this that device
butlers that would look like I said
before as I is half a speed reducer yeah
half the speed reason and then the other
one was the robotic arm needed to move
faster well that's reason we use a speed
reducers because the robotic the servo
motor wants to go really really fast and
we need to slow down on the rotation so
talking with the robotics company and
they want a 100 to one reduction in
speed and that's huge to be able to
handle right yeah how does one make a
hundred to one reduction in speed in
such a short amount of time well you
take something like this and you put
instead of four pins you put in 15 yeah
and then you make another one that has
14 and then what happens is you join the
two rotors together these two center
pieces interesting and then the output
is one of them is stationary and the
other outer ring moves just a little
teeny okay so kind of like gears but
it's kind of like ears but it's a little
different yeah okay this is a much more
complex Center than than a year yeah and
again these that idea was tried 100
years ago very interesting that it was
tried hundred years but the surface is
there just wasn't the math back then you
know use this is high-end matrix math
putting this all together and optimizing
this shape so that it rolls properly and
we're keeping the contact points under
media degrees apart yeah this is very
interesting I think this can be used in
a lot of applications in robotics I have
a lot to obviously learn about
engineering and its applications but I
know that lots of kids as they build
robots for like FIRST Robotics and
whatnot
are always interested in how to apply to
new parts to maximize what they're doing
it if they can like you said decrease
the RPM of a servo that's huge
yep yeah so the other applications are
ingest in general if you were gonna go
out and you wanted to build something
with the mechanism so if you were to buy
it use a four bar linkage for something
you can you know that works with there's
only two points you're trying to make
that works just fine but if you start to
say hey I've got to do multiple part
into multiple movements in this thing
and I'm now you're getting into a six
seven eight bar linkage this is going to
do a much better job for you yeah yeah
yeah okay so the more complexity this
does a better job yeah yeah you know if
you're doing a landing gear and all you
care about is up and down yeah yeah
those are two points yeah the the four
bar linkage works great yeah yeah
there's no reason to drag my stuff in
the right way but if you're doing
something more complicated then there's
a lot of value to that and so another
example would be drug injection so you
can when when a if you have like an
EpiPen or something like that when the
needle pierces the skin it has to be
going perfectly straight yes and it
can't be rotating yeah okay and it can't
be moving sideways yeah okay so if this
is a problem that would work if you
wanted a four bar linkage you could
replace a couple of the normal bearings
in a four bar language with some of my
bearings and you could have a system
where the bar comes down and then it
comes completely straight while it's
doing the injection interesting okay and
there's there are some ways to do that
using a linkage with the symmetry but
then you've used up all the degrees of
freedom with just the one one part
interesting so there's applications of
this in medicine and biotech healthcare
oh yeah there's interesting anything
that moves if it's complicated that's it
yeah if it's complicated the other one
is my website I have an example of a
corkscrew yeah okay so there's two
things two takeaways from that corkscrew
examples first of all is that I can vary
the mechanical advantage any way I want
so in that case I have a mechanical
advantage starting out high and going
low because the forces start high and go
low so it's a concept that the
mechanical advantage should follow the
force secondly you know at home I have a
the expensive William seminoma cork
remover and it's a rack and pinion and
that's a constant force system so that
it starts out really hard to move but it
also is driven the the gearing there
first of all it has to be well
lubricated to work at all and it's got a
very clunky feel to it so with yet to
prove it out but I'm pretty sure with
some decent material science and some
you know interesting work we could have
this have a silky feel to it it's very
very different yeah
instead of that really hug hard pull up
at first that yeah for a system to
potentially move with a greater amount
of smoothness yes yeah yeah that's it's
that's another one of those there's
there's there's a certain
really beautiful feeling too when
something moves more smoothly like when
it can slow down more smoothly or when
you can pull it up more smoothly it will
it it will be a revolution in the way
anything in the way any mechanism works
it's going to be a revolution because
it's going to have a very different
touch than what people are used to
that's that's it yeah that's really
interesting and that's beautifully it
sounds so beautiful and this feels
really interesting it's as though I
haven't liked the applications of this
type of technology are have so many
different applications yeah I think
there's thousands of ways this is going
to work I think the the somewhere
there's going to be a design lab that's
going to put a lot of energy into how do
you make me instruments work or you know
anything that moves so like the
automobile company we're talking about
hey maybe I can get the look and feel of
how the glove box opens and closes to
change that's right okay so when you
open the goes box you get this beautiful
feel to it yeah the way that the vehicle
seat moves as well the seat moves how it
moves
maybe now there's a table that pops out
from somewhere and because of the
flexibility of my system that table will
just jump up yeah yeah and it'll have a
very interesting mechanism in it and
it'll feel unique and and then it'll pop
out of the way it'll be perfectly gone
yeah yeah so those are the kind of
things that are said yeah yeah this is
this is very cool Tom we we actually we
really wish that that this gets
implemented into the use cases that it
needs to be in as soon as possible and
it's great to see you coming up with
this after a long period of figuring out
what I like the most robust applications
of this and coming up with
and getting forward so we're I'm looking
for my first customer so my goals this
year are to establish a CAD partner get
a first customer hopefully to one for
the speed reducer and one for some
general mechanism work and then finally
I've got this grant application out
there and so yes I'll find out in a few
days whether or not I get that's great
yeah the grant application and then the
applications getting customers and CAD
partners so that's awesome and hopefully
people that watch can potentially come
on board and help out as needed as well
so thank you very much for coming on and
teaching us about this has been very
interesting Tom thank you thank you
thank you 21 geometry comm check out the
link in the bio below also continue
supporting the artists and entrepreneurs
you believe in check out Co fesses links
below go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world huge
thank you for tuning in
give us your comments and your thoughts
below thank you and we'll see you soon
bye